here's a real fun story we got this from
timcast.com New York students make deep
fake viral video of principal making
racist threats
yo this one's crazy I can't even read
what they made him say but to put it
simply
New York students made a deep fake of
their principle making racist threats
what happened this is going to be wild
do they well how does this resolve three
high school students in Putnam County
New York have caused a lot of trouble
for their school after making deep deep
fake videos of their middle school
principal going on a racist rant against
black students and threatening to shoot
them we're doomed man we're doomed
you're never gonna know what you're not
gonna know what's real you're not gonna
know it's fake you're not going to want
to let me let you know I saw another
everyone who runs for office will have a
hunter Biden laptop look at this I saw
this uh article from wired it says after
The Last of Us everything will be
transmedia the HBO series success has
changed the game expect to see a lot
more World building franchises
I saw that and I saw this and then I had
a vision
uh slowly creeping while I was sleeping
and it is that uh this this Vision in my
mind
is we are going to have neuralink and
you are going to sit down and you are
going to say computer craft me a
universe where elves are at war with
Orcs And I am a writer of the north
who's come to save the Elvish people of
gorwin and then it'll start it'll render
it'll be like rendering neurolink
plug-in ready and you'll plug in your
eyes will turn white you'll fall back
and you will live 70 years in this
reality and you may be in it right now
but I'm going to create it my own
language with the air where I'll be like
computer run one red four seven nine two
which means more difficulty there I want
Greener trees here but it's going to be
a language that knows between it and I
no one else wants so what's the purpose
of that life you're the guy you're the
guy you're Neo in The Matrix so you're
just you're in the Pod think about this
to augment it you are officially you're
in the Pod you've eaten the bugs think
about what you were saying about how
we're never gonna know what's going to
we're going to be real or not yo this
presidential election cycle is going to
be Bonkers there's going to be videos
that look have you guys seen it excuse
me
all right I think I fought this knees
yes have you guys seen the new MID
Journey photos not the new ones
indistinguishable for me it's crazy it's
really crazy mid Journey five I think it
is I I hold the photo AI yeah my D
Journey someone mid-journey
someone's gonna be like make a picture
of Joe Biden with so they got me they
got me so I I had to buy a house a year
and a half ago right my family moved
from Washington DC to Tampa Florida and
I follow these real estate accounts and
I follow these real estate accounts like
look at houses look at houses that are
available and one of my favorite
accounts posts this court the most
beautiful coolest house I've ever seen
was a house inside of a rock in the
desert and at a pool and it had all this
and I was like wow what is this what
does this cost I've never seen anything
like it and it was all AI oh they got me
I chucked a like atom and everything and
I'm looking I'm swiping and in the
caption low in the caption they're like
oh by the way I generated this image
from AI it's not a real house what but
they were selling you a house so I'm
already living inside so I'm already
living in The Matrix I couldn't tell the
difference I'm telling you I wasn't
trying to be stupid I couldn't tell the
difference between the fake AI generated
uh Boulder house in the middle of the
desert it was just some cool like Frank
Lloyd Wright looking house right it was
all fake none of it was real you know to
answer your question from earlier should
we let the AI run these programs never
no we should never let an AI run a
program ever we should always use them
as advisors and let humans run the
programs take a look at this image
you can you pull the image up search so
this is fake this is mid-journey and it
looks like someone just took a panorama
here's here's some here's another one
Hawaii fake image here's another one
fake image a kid is going to be born
today
who will see photographs that look real
and someone will tell them it's real
what is this this is not even wow this
is crazy stuff yeah and uh people are
gonna a little kid's gonna grow up how
are they going to know this isn't that
easy how will a child know the
difference
a jungle they're they're they're asking
it to make panoramas but if a kid born
today is online and looks up this date
at this time and they get a fake image
of it how will they know the difference
between the actual image of trump and
the fake image of trump when they're
identical that all the people with their
avatars AI avatars as their profile
pictures is disturbing beyond measure
it's not you those are not you do not
yeah don't fall into it it's so tempting
it makes you look cool
[Music]
my name is rain and was created using
version 5 of mid Journey which came out
today my Creator JS films wanted to hear
how I sound with voice.ai and how I
would look when being animated by did
wow what do you think we're getting
dangerously close to people just
retreating to fake realities and y'all
might already be in we already Retreat
to fake realities I'm saying this could
be one
that we're in right now I mean you ask
uh so like real Tim chose to plug in in
a pod somewhere I mean or are we on that
show maybe it's you maybe we're in your
simulation bro I think there's a lot of
people that live in digital realities
right now I think I agree I just think
it's not the the there's right now
they're not real there is you can tell
they're cartoons still they are doing
tests on whether or not the universe is
a simulation with lasers or something I
don't know exactly know what that means
or how you've improved that but there
are a lot of people who genuinely
believe that we're actually living in a
simulation and I wonder if it's a
simulation or based on what we want as
people it's actually just a video game
so like a kid that plays Minecraft for
10 hours a day how's that not him living
inside of a digital simulator it is but
imagine if you could plug in and live 70
years in Minecraft
in a day in a day or in in two hours
like Roy on Rick and Morty you slow time
down time dilation in The Matrix that's
what uh it's only if you forget that
you're in a game is when it starts to
get tediously dangerous like if you but
because they're cartoony still you
always sort of know although when you're
in a storybook when you're reading a
book sometimes you feel like you're in
the book 70 years and like but you know
that means like like that means like
feeding tubes right like my wife's done
like NICU stuff where like to keep a
human being alive on a machine is
unbelie to look there are people right
now that are alive because of machines
right there there are millions of them
all over the country and those are some
of the most depressing looking
individuals you have ever seen it's not
cool it's not some little thing from
Star Trek it's not Iron Man it's like
you you are you have a tube in every
orifice of your body you have needles
and blood and everything shoved right in
there to try and keep a Human Being
Alive through a machine is a horrible
process it would be you would so you
would have to do that yeah it wouldn't
be that right it would you would go into
your your major bricks and time would
slow down for your perception so an hour
would go by it seems like an hour but
it's only two seconds in real life so
you will live a year in this literally
it will feel like a year has gone by
with conversations every day you've
slept 365 times you wake up you take the
goggles off and it's an hour later or
five minutes later like you can slow
down perception and time has no meaning
when you are here's the worst part Benny
when you finally come out of the game
you're like some 28 year old fat dude
with Cheetos covered all over your shirt
and you're sitting in your basement and
your kids your kids are sitting there
looking at you being like
I was playing a video game
it was called Temple's show no it's the
Benny Johnson show bro you're in your
game or you could speed up time so that
someone could serve a 70-year sentence
but to them it would only feel like 20
minutes so I'll tell you would you ever
do that I'll tell you I'll tell you this
to remove that return Society for 70
years without without so I'm so I'm
driving out here I'm driving out here
Tim lives in the middle of nowhere in
the beautiful mountains and I'm like
looking around and I was like you know
if if you were a god-hating atheist you
would sit here and stare at these
beautiful mountains and look at these
tall trees and breathe this fresh crisp
air and there's nothing but you in the
sunset and nature and you would say this
is all I need and you would feel
spiritual if you go and you look up at
the redwood trees that are 2 000 years
old and 2 000 feet tall in California
and you look up at them you have a
spiritual moment I don't care who you
are I don't care if you hate God if you
have your own problems with God you
understand spirituality you take your
shoes off and your socks off and you put
your feet in the dirt under those
redwood trees and you look around you
take a deep breath you'll understand
there's something bigger than you in the
universe and that spirituality is always
going to be needed by people there's no
digital environment that can replace it
and I would say if you feel like if
you're listening this conversation you
think that would be cool the neural link
get get out of your basement go walk
through a Park start with that go get
some sunlight and then realize that this
world's already a beautiful magical
unbelie like breathtakingly gorgeous
place and it's all there and most of
it's free because a lot of its natural
part national parks and there's probably
one right down the street from you here
in America because the federal
government owns half the land in America
and you should possibly consider like
enjoying this gorgeous Earth as God made
it and not looking for some cheap
digital substitute created by people who
hate you yes cities cities are not fun
places right now what about augmented
reality like where you could still
experience everything but yeah why would
I want to augment Niagara Falls you
stand there and you watch Niagara Falls
and you watch the rainbow over Niagara
Falls you got
while the barrels were going Downstream
like Houdini need it like Houdini went
down you put on the goggles and you're
watching Niagara Falls but then you're
also watching barrels and a guy is
jumping from the barrel to Barrel while
the barrels go off the cliff you're just
watching it it would be entertaining I
would prefer Niagara Falls without that
but Harry Houdini literally went over
Niagara Falls and barely survived yeah
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time